ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Oscar special friend Angie Dickinson
I picked this flower last week in the
lovely Crystal Room of the Beverly Hills
Hotel we were there to present the
Oscars for technical and scientific
achievement and during the course of the
evening three special Oscars were
awarded the first was presented to Ray
Dolby who with his associate yo and Alan
have revolution revolutionized the sound
that meets our ears many major motion
picture sound
I'm sorry many motion picture sound
facilities rely on Dolby equipment the
Gordon East Sawyer award went to Henry
cook chief designer of the cooks feed
pan crow fixed focal length and very
tall zoom lenses which means when you're
taking pictures of your kids at home you
can zoom in for a close-up and the third
award was given to Eastman Kodak for 100
years of service to the motion picture
industry it was a wonderful gathering of
the technical geniuses whose work makes
possible almost everything we do on the
screen
the Dolby D trademark has marquee value
and theater owners have confidence in
the most reliable Cora field engineers
the industry has ever known ray Dolby
and yo inhale
I want to acknowledge the Academy and
the Technical Committee and the Board of
Governors for this great honor
I'm delighted thank you very much it's a
very proud moment for us to feel that
we've been more than compensated for
their food we put into this program
speaking for myself I'm proud as hell
thank you very much 25 other people have
received the Gordon E Sawyer award I'm
very happy to present number six
to Gordon Henry cook
of special significance is the advance
in the state-of-the-art of zoom lens
design which has reached the point where
zoom lenses can be considered as the
prime tool on the camera rather than the
accessory just for gimmick type purposes
thank you so much
tonight the Board of Governors of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences presents to Eastman Kodak a
special honorary Oscar for its 100-year
uninterrupted legacy of service and
achievement Academy and all of you for
making this moment possible this is very
special to us and thanks very much for
making movies
it was a beautiful evening I'm in awe of
all this technical and scientific
expertise and I congratulate the Oscar
winners
you